>>Narrator: Every school day
afternoon, several students
from Bravo Medical Magnet High
School take a five-minute walk
to continue their education
on the campus of one
of the most prestigious
universities in the country.
>>Lauren: Admitting, Valencia.
Lauren speaking.
>>Narrator: Some of them
intern at the University
of Southern California
Hospital, learning the ropes
of the medical office world.
>>Echo cart, so just put CA.
>>Narrator: A select group of
students in Bravo's Science,
Technology, and Research
Program, STAR, and the Engineering
for Health Academy, EHA, work
in labs on the USC campus.
>>Mark: The work we're doing
is taking a blind person
and putting a computer
chip in their eye.
And by doing so, this
computer chip allows them
to wirelessly connect to a camera.
So the camera is worn in the
glasses and sends the information
to the brain, allowing
the blind person to see.
>>Hardik: Basically, I'm going to be
putting different amounts of current
through the resistor and measuring
the corresponding temperature
for that current.
>>Mark: Education has to
be much more hands on.
We can't continue to just
educate students in silos
and not integrate technologies in
this case into medical applications.
>>What are you working on?
>>Hardik: Right now, I'm just
trying to smooth out the output
of this circuit right now--
>>Mark: We're providing a very
unique laboratory environment
so students can come over here
and actually have a very
hands-on type of experience.
>>Narrator: Bravo students
work with researchers
and graduate students five days
a week during their senior year.
>>Faizan: And I have been
testing my compounds,
which are my drugs,
over and over again.
And the compounds will tell us
if these compounds have any
sort of anti-cancer activity.
So like if they basically--
trying to find a cure for cancer.
>>Joe: And so Faizan has
helped to contribute to--
>>Narrator: Bravo physiology
teacher, Joe Cocozza,
helped establish the
partnerships between Bravo and USC.
>>Joe: Well, these
are extremities too.
>>Narrator: He now splits his
time teaching classes at Bravo
and doing outreach
for the university.
>>Joe: I talk to the principal
investigator, find out what kind
of research is being done there.
Then I explain to them
carefully the time commitment
that the students need to make.
The students are in lab
two hours a day minimally.
And the students have to understand
that they're actually
partaking in real research.
It's not a class, it's
not on a bell schedule.
So that if they're in a
middle of a procedure,
they can't just get up and walk out.
>>Nouri: What our students are
doing today is testing the activity
of several drugs that we
designed against HIV 1 integrase.
These high school students
are very talented.
These are really cream of crop.
They are the best of the
best in the country, in fact.
When I was a high school student, I
would have been so happy just to go
in the lab, wash the dishes.
But now, my students actually
are doing experiments.
And these experiments are
really very high level,
sophisticated experiments, just the
same experiments that the post docs
and graduate students are doing.
So the high school students are
really-- this is fantastic for them.
They can do very cool stuff.
>>Joe: I think we have
a real commitment
that it does take a
village to educate anyone.
And so we envisioned
the outreach program
at the Engineering Research Center
as having a brigade of mentors.
>>Tino: And when it's such a
small amount, we really do need
to make sure that it's exact.
>>Tino: I graduated
from Bravo in 1998.
Being a mentor to all the young
high school students that used to go
through Bravo, I mean, it's kind
of completing a circle in that,
you know, I've received a lot of
mentorship and help or whatnot.
And then now it makes me feel even
more grown to actually be able
to teach the next generation
of scientists.
And hopefully they
decide to say in research,
because we really need their help.
>>Narrator: The relationship
with Bravo and other schools
in the area is part
of USC's commitment
to serving the local community.
>>Hit the transfer button.
>>Cesar: This past year alone,
between the faculty, staff, doctors,
nurses, we've raised one point two
million out of our own pockets,
and 100 percent of that goes
back into community programs.
There's just a fundamental commitment
that USC's in for the long haul.
We're not going anywhere.
We know the schools
are not going anywhere.
And if there's a personnel
change, we reintroduce ourselves,
and that each year we're
coming back with the resources.
Always seeking new resources.
>>Narrator: As part of a grant from
the National Science Foundation,
USC partnerships extend to elementary
school classrooms, where elementary,
high school, and graduate
students learn from each other.
>>Joe: And they're all doing
hands on, project-based learning,
and they're all helping one anothher.
And it translates in both directions,
because the older mentors are
teaching some of the skills
and the content, but
they're also learning
from the younger kids what
does it take to be able
to communicate effectively
to someone younger than you.
>>Narrator: The USC-Bravo partnership
has accomplished much more
than its primary goal of giving
high school students a window
on their future.
>>Faizan: Bravo has been great.
This is like the only place that
offers me a chance to work at a lab.
Basically, I was in
between pharmacology
or pursue something else, and
this experience has helped me.
Yeah, it's actually pretty fun.
>>Narrator: For more
information about what works
in education, go to edutopia.org.